mit putin erreicht mit seinem sinnlosen
mörderischen krieg den er auch begonnen
hat damit die ukraine nicht in die nato
eintritt statt dessen hat er jetzt mit
finnland und schweden zwei neue nato
länder vor der tür in beiden ländern
stimmten die parlamente für einen
schnellstmöglichen beitritt beide länder
übrigens regiert von frauen die putin
die stirn bieten und dazu noch im falle
von sanna marin aus finden die wir
gerade schon kurz gesehen hat die
jüngste regierungschef in der welt
finnlands regierungschef in st anna
marin und russen despot wladimir putin
sie könnten unterschiedlicher nicht sein
die galionsfigur der neuen polit
generation junger stilvoll im amt seit
2009 10 damals die jüngste
regierungschef in
diktator krieg sehr ex-geheimdienstchef
sie verheiratet mit einem mann markus
drei können ehemaliger fußballspieler
sie haben eine tochter
putins ehe gescheitert laut inoffizielle
quellen hat er mehrere kinder von drei
verschiedenen frauen er regiert aus dem
prozent kreml dem prunkvollen
regierungspalast in moskau sie aus einem
holzhaus in helsinki ihrem amtssitz auch
genannt käse rente zu deutsch sommer
küste früher war sie verkäuferin in
einer bäckerei
stadtoberhaupt von 144 millionen
menschen sie regiert nur rund fünf
millionen brisant im oktober 2020 liegt
sie sich für ein fotoshooting gewagten
outfits ablichten er ist er für macho
fotos bekannt oben ohne auf dem pferd
mit einem tiger kämpfend als taucher der
zufällig antike vasen findet finnland
war bisher neutral möchte aus angst vor
russland nun in die nato kein wunder er
führt überall krieg ukraine syrien
georgien zusammen mit schweden hat
sonder marin nun den beitritt finnland
geplant das friedens- und
verteidigungsbündnis wächst ein dorn im
auge des russischen despoten marien wagt
was kein finnen chef vor ihr gewagt hat
eine schöne mutige frau die putin die
stirn bietet ganz nach dem motto die
schöne und das biest
h